YURI GRINSHTEYN: You've seen
how to set up monitoring
and learning for GKE services.
But what do you do
when an alert fires?
How can you tell
what's actually wrong?
Today I'm going to show
you how to troubleshoot
services running on GKE.
This is The Stack Doctor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of my favorite new features
in cloud or operations for GKE
is the Alerts Timeline.
It lets you quickly see if
any of the infrastructure
or workloads in your
workspace are having an issue.
If an incident is triggered,
you can mouse over it
in the timeline to get
more information about it.
For example, here's an
infrastructure incident.
It's telling you
when it started,
which resource is
having an issue,
and which alerting policy
triggered the incident.
From here, you can click the
View Incident link to get
the full incident details.
The Details screen
shows you exactly what
happened to trigger the
incident, which resources were
involved, and how
the networks you're
tracking in the
alerting policy changed
to exceed the threshold.
From here you can click
on the View Logs link
at the bottom to figure
out exactly what happened.
That takes you to
the Logs Explorer,
where the query
is already written
for you to pull the logs
with just the resources that
triggered the incident.
The log entries show you
exactly what happened
that caused the incident.
In this example, the
containers are crashing.
Now, figuring out what
to do to fix the problem
may not be easy, but getting
to this point where you
know exactly what's wrong is.
As you may recall from
an earlier episode,
it's also possible
to integrate traces
and logs using OpenTelemetry
or other methods.
If you've done that, you'll
see this icon next to the log
entries, letting you know
that an associated trace
is available.
Click on that icon, and
click View Trace Details.
This will take you to the
trace for the request that
generated that log.
You can then try to determine
whether the problem has
to do with the downstream
service or a dependency.
And there you are.
Here are the trace details.
If you want more information,
click the View and Trace link
to go to the trace list and
see the full list of tracers,
including this one.
Thanks for joining me today.
We looked at the
new Alerts Timeline
in the GKE Monitoring
dashboard, and learned
how to use it to
get from an incident
all the way to the logs
and associated traces
we need to troubleshoot
our service.
I hope these new features help
you run your services on GKE
more reliably.
Thanks for watching, and
come back soon for more.
This is the Stack Doctor.
Stay healthy out there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]